Ang mga neural network ay isang makapangyarihang klase ng mga machine learning algorithm
at marami itong uri
hindi posibleng bigyan ng sapat na atensyon ang mga neural network
sa isang panimulang video
tulad nito dito ilalarawan lang natin ang ilang mahahalagang bahagi
ng isang neural network at ang kabuuang proseso
para maunawaan natin kung paano makakatulong ang quantum computing
ang neural network ay isang konektadong graph ng mga neuron
ang neuron ay simpleng bagay lang na nagtataglay ng isang numero
at ang numerong iyon ay madalas na tinatawag na activation kung gaano
ka-on o ka-off ang neuron
ang mga neuron ay nakaayos sa dalawang layer
at ang unang layer ay ang input layer
at ang huli ay ang output layer
sa pagitan nito ay may mga layer na ginagamit sa pagpoproseso na tinatawag na
hidden layers ang activation ng
input layer ay direktang kinukuha mula sa datos na susuriin
tulad ng shading ng pixel sa isang imahe
ang mga activation ng susunod na hidden layer ay tinutukoy
ng mga neuron sa input layer
at ng mga weight na kinakatawan ng mga linya na nagkokonekta sa lahat ng neuron
sa input layer patungo sa lahat ng neuron sa
susunod na layer ibig sabihin tinutukoy natin ang activation
ng isang neuron sa hidden layer
sa pamamagitan ng weighted sum ng lahat ng
input activation maaari rin tayong
mag-apply ng bias isang uri ng shift
maaaring gusto nating i-activate ang isang neuron
sa hidden layer hindi lang kung positibo ang weighted sum
kundi kung lalampas ito sa isang malaking threshold
madalas na nag-aapply tayo ng kumplikadong function para makakuha ng activation
sa pagitan ng zero at isa tulad ng hyperbolic tangent
o minsan naman ay isang
rectified linear unit hindi mo na kailangang mag-alala
tungkol dito ngayon ang tanging
mahalagang dapat tandaan tungkol sa mga function na ito
ay na sila ay non-linear
para ang network sa kabuuan ay naglalaman ng parehong linear
at nonlinear na bahagi
ang parehong weighted sum ng mga activation ngayon naman
simula sa mga activation ng
unang hidden layer at sa mga bagong weight
ay umabot sa susunod na hidden layer
ito ay nagpapatuloy hanggang sa huling layer na siyang output
ang output layer ay may mga neuron na naaayon sa
mga kategorya at ang mga activation ay nagsasabi sa atin
kung gaano ka-sigurado ang network sa klasipikasyon
kaya ang mga output na kategorya sa pagsusuri ng imahe ay maaaring
aso pusa hamster at iba pa
at ang activation na point nine five sa
neuron ng aso ay nagpapahiwatig ng mataas na antas ng katiyakan na
ang imahe ay ng aso maaari mong simulan ang iyong neural network
sa isang random na set ng mga weight
at bias o mula sa isang kilalang makatwirang panimulang configuration
pero ang ideya ay suriin
kung gaano kahusay na nag-uuri ang iyong neural network
at pagbutihin ito gumagamit tayo ng cost function para ilarawan
kung paano lumalayo ang ating neural network mula sa
tamang klasipikasyon kasama dito ang pag-kuha ng
pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng aktwal na halaga ng isang imahe
halimbawa ang halaga na isa sa neuron
para sa aso at zero sa lahat ng ibang output neuron
at ang mga hinulang halaga
isinasama natin ito sa lahat ng kategorya
kaya sinusubaybayan natin hindi lang kung ang tamang kategorya ang
pinaka-na-activate kundi maaari rin tayong
subaybayan kung ang mga maling activation ay nababawasan
isinasama ito sa lahat ng halimbawa sa ating training set
at nakakakuha ng cost pagkatapos ay ina-vary natin
ang mga parameter tulad ng mga weight sa bawat layer
sa pagitan ng lahat ng neuron at ang mga bias sa lahat ng mga ito
ginagamit ang mga classical na optimisation routine
para hanapin ang lokal na minimum sa cost function
kung walang gagawin para bawasan ang complexity nito
maisip mo kung gaano
ka-astronomikong parameter space ang ating na-set up dito
isipin ang isang neural network na dinisenyo para suriin ang mga imahe na may
isang libong pixel lamang ang neural network na ito ay maaaring may isang libo
input neuron isang hidden layer lang
at binary output tulad ng pusa o aso
ito ang pinakasimpleng kaso
at katumbas pa rin ito ng isang libo sa isang libo
o isang milyong weight sa pagitan ng input at hidden layer
at isa pang dalawang libo sa pagitan ng
hidden at output layer
posibleng may isang libo rin o
higit pang mga bias kaya ang simpleng neural network na ito ay katumbas
ng mahigit isang milyong parameter bagama't para maging patas
ang mga modernong algorithm ay karaniwang gumagawa ng mga simplipikasyon
sa mga classical neural network
at may mga buong larangan na nakatuon sa paggawa ng minimisation na ito
na posible at kahit na episyente
pero nananatili ang katotohanang ito ay isang napaka-
mataas na dimensional na problema
at ang pag-train ng isang neural network
ay maaaring maging napaka-time consuming
at mahal ang quantum neural network o qnn
ay gumagana sa pamamagitan ng una munang pag-load ng input data
at pagkatapos ay pag-apply ng mga quantum circuit
na katumbas ng mga weight sa pagitan ng mga layer
at sa wakas ay isang layer ng sukat
ilang mahahalagang punto tungkol dito ang data
loading at ang mga weighting ay mga linear na operasyon
ngunit ang mga sukat ay nonlinear
kaya tulad ng mga classical neural network mayroon tayong
parehong linear at nonlinear na bahagi
gayundin ang mga weight circuit
ay mayroon pa ring variational parameter
kaya mayroon pa ring classical minimisation na kailangang gawin
siyempre bahagya lang ang natuklasan natin tungkol sa quantum neural
network pero umaasa kaming magpatuloy kang matuto tungkol sa mga aplikasyon
ng mga quantum neural network
at iba pang quantum machine learning na aplikasyon
kasama ang IBM Quantum